The joe rogan experience
base.
Talk about this.
I can talk about this.
Absolutely.
Okay.
I think I can other smooshy there.
I mean if you want to go,
if you want to back things up there,
man,
how fucked is that picture?
That picture's Walrus is sitting on a concrete floor with,
with her arm through.
It's a her right with her arm through a fucking prison cage.
That's so dark,
man.
So the story of smooshy is,
you know,
she come in from like wild caught 18 months of age,
200 pounds.
He's this big,
he's a big pillow.
Beautiful Amy.
She's a baby.
She's not,
she didn't come in alone.
She comes up with some other animals,
uh,
walruses where they catch them,
Russia and the Black Sea.
So she comes in and we start then now we got to get blood from him.
We got to see if these animals are healthy.
So the way you do it with an untrained animal,
you throw a big net on him,
physically jumped,
grabbed them.
The fet sticks a needle in their vet or train or someone and they go to take the
blood out.
Well during this procedure,
there was another walrus there that we were doing the procedure on.
And here's smooshy who's,
you know,
climbing up on the other walrus.
Let's make things very difficult.
He Mat,
as you can imagine,
these guys are like linebackers.
So all I do is I put my hands in front of her face like this and she opened up
her nostrils and,
and I,
I remember this vividly,
she took a big breath.
She started to follow me.
After that,
I started to backup.
This animal followed me,
big eyes staring at me,
following me.
I'd never seen anything like this before.
I thought it was like,
this is going to be just a onetime thing.
She just followed me because this just made her nervous.
What had happened at 18 months of age and at that specific time was I had
imprinted on her.
That's what happens in the wild.
You're a mother,
Walrus,
you shit out a calf that animal's going to tattoo to its brain,
your smell,
your sight,
the sound,
everything so that you can be identified in,
you know,
heard of hundreds.
This happened at 18 months of phases.
So she imprinted on you.
Just maybe she was her,
you imprinted on her because she was panicking.
I think it has to have been,
it was at that moment,
and no question because I know it's the baby.
While this was all going down,
and you can imagine the stress of being caught only maybe months before
separated from your mother or witnessing her mother die in a harvest.
Jesus Christ.
So this happened.
So this animal I imprinted on her.
Well this is,
this is an anomaly.
This doesn't happen.
This isn't,
hey,
here's food.
We're like best friends now.
Great.
This is your my mommy.
That's the relationship we have.
It's crazy.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's intense.
So then when you start factoring in the fact that she's in the pool with a lot
of crazy chlorine values and she's getting chemical burns and everything else,
and I'm like,
so you almost have a,
a paternal relationship with this?
Definitely have.
I definitely have a paternal hours.
Wow.
That's crazy.
And all because of the fact they're not cleaning the water.
She's getting sick while there's more to it than that point.
She come in at 2004,
so she's probably 10,
a little over 10 years old now.
Um,
this relationship also turned into,
created some problems.
It manifested in like,
you know,
physical manifestations of stress.
She developed this uncontrollable regurgitating issue where she doesn't keep her
fish down,
she pukes it up and it's from anxiety,
from separation anxiety because I'm fast forwarding a bit from that moment of
the imprint to now or well to prior to now of course.
So there was,
there was a lot of challenges that that relationship post.
So you try to train well,
so I developed this,
this system where the animal consumes fish and thereafter consumed Jello.
I would teach her to eat the Gel and play with the Jello.
So try to keep her from throwing up the,
the nutrients that are keeping her from gaining weight and being healthy.
Right.
So I tried to train all the other people on this,
you know,
tried to wean myself out a number of times.
But again,
so the relationship was a blessing in the fact that this is,
this is amazing,
this is crazy.
And it was also an,
and more so now like an absolute curse because giving a shit about an animal in
that at that level,
like what you're saying,
that the parental relationship,
that bond,
that's tough,
man.
Like to see what she's going through and then you start realizing like,
I dunno what I can do.
Yeah.
To save her because she's going to die.
Okay.
Wow.
Yeah.